We can have no guarantee that a super intelligent
AI is going to do what we want.
Once we're creating something ten, a hundred,
a thousand, a million times more intelligent
than we are it would be insane to think that
we could really like rigorously control what
it does.
It may discover aspects of the universe that
we don't even imagine at this point.
However, my best intuition and educated guess
is that much like raising a human child, if
we raise the young AGI in a way that's imbued
with compassion, love and understanding and
if we raise the young AGI to fully understand
human values and human culture then we're
maximizing the odds that as this AGI gets
beyond our rigorous control at least it's
own self-modification and evolution is imbued
with human values and culture and with compassion
and connection.
So I would rather have an AGI that understood
human values and culture become super intelligent
than one that doesn't understand even what
we're about.
And I would rather have an AGI that was doing
good works like advancing science and medicine
and doing elder care and education becomes
super intelligent than an AGI that was being,
for example, a spy system, a killer drone
coordination system or an advertising agency.
So even when you don't have a full guarantee
I think we can do things that commonsensically
will bias the odds in a positive way.
Now, in terms of nearer-term risks regarding
AI, I think we now have a somewhat unpleasant
situation where much of the world's data,
including personal data about all of us and
our bodies and our minds and our relationships
and our tastes, much of the world's data and
much of the world's AI fire power are held
by a few large corporations, which are acting
in close concert with a few large governments.
In China the connection between big tech and
the government apparatus is very clear, but
in the U.S. as well.
I mean there was a big noise about Amazon's
new office, well 25,000 Amazon employees are
going in Crystal City Virginia right next-door
to the Pentagon; there could be a nice big
data pipe there if they want.
We in the U.S. as well have very close connections
between big tech and government.
Anyone can Google Eric Schmidt verses NSA
as well.
So there's a few big companies with close
government connections hoarding everyone's
data, developing AI processing power, hiring
most of the AI PhDs and it's not hard to see
that this can bring up some ethical issues
in the near-term, even before we get to superhuman
super intelligences potentially turning the
universe into paper clips.
And decentralization of AI can serve to counteract
these nearer-term risks in a pretty palpable
way.
So as a very concrete example, one of our
largest AI development offices for SingularityNET,
and for Hanson Robotics the robotics company
I'm also involved with, is in Addis Ababa
Ethiopia.
We have 25 AI developers and 40 or 50 interns
there.
I mean these young Ethiopians aren't going
to get a job for Google, Facebook, Tencent
or Baidu except in very rare cases when they
managed to get a work visa to go to one of
these countries somehow.
And many of the AI applications of acute interest
in those countries, say AI for analyzing agriculture
and preventing agricultural disease or AI
for credit scoring for the unbank to enable
micro finance, AI problems of specific interest
in sub-Saharan Africa don't get a heck of
a lot of attention these days.
AI wizardry from young developers there doesn't
have a heck of a lot of market these days
so you've got a both a lot of the market and
a lot of the developer community that's sort
of shut out by the siloing of AI inside a
few large tech companies and military organizations.
And this is both a humanitarian ethical problem
because there's a lot of value being left
on the table and a lot of value not being
delivered, but it also could become a different
sort of crisis because if you have a whole
bunch of brilliant young hackers throughout
the developing world who aren't able to fully
enter into the world economy there's a lot
of other less pleasant things than work for
Google or Tencent that these young hackers
could choose to spend their time on.
So I think getting the whole world fully pulled
into the AI economy in terms of developers
being able to monetize their code and application
developers having an easy way to apply AI
to the problems of local interest to them,
I mean this is ethically positive right now
in terms of doing good and in terms of diverting
effort away from people doing bad things out
of frustration.